i was very robotic okay yeah that's what
we want yeah yeah very right yeah 100
like again this is this comes down to
being going back to the whole discipline
and being obsessed every single day i've
done the same thing day in day out like
structure was on point day plan was
written out what was that literally
you're getting in the morning i'm
checking my emails my links in messages
i'm looking at my alerts on linkedin
what time is this um typically back in
the day i've gotten at eight not anymore
getting it rfa okay i don't know right
it's getting later now okay so you've
got an a yeah so you're checking in your
linkedin emails yeah uh looking at my
links and alerts
so i'll go on my linkedin alerts and
that will show me anyone that has
updated their linkedin profile
so i can find out any new projects
they're working on if somebody's gone to
a new company they've changed off okay
right he's gone to that company that's a
new projects i can approach
mapping out the market in the morning
looking at posted jobs in the morning
seeing what companies are hiring
catching up with all my
senior contractors find out whether
where they're going what the plans are
and then the minute it hit half eight i
was on the phone down 30 minutes just on
it yeah so the first half an hour in the
morning it was just like getting my day
planned sorted get everything on check
looking at all my messages planning and
then halfway it was militant on the
phone what we're doing what bd
i was always a bd guy um so halfway
until what one yeah so literally
so in the start of my career it was
split i was you know
halfway until you know half nine talking
to candidates and then i was you know
doing vd from half nine until 12
and then from 1 30 until six clients and
then after that candidates i was
structured like that but then towards
the latter end of my career which is
bdbd that's what i wanted to do um
but i've always been very big on being
on the phone
so i was always making sure i was
dialing so it's so key that you're not
spending all your time on emails and
your linkedin recruiter you need to be
on the phone 100 so
um having that militant structure of
hits half 8 you're on the phone that was
the key thing for me but yeah i think um
my structure was very rigid i was always
making sure i was
hitting the targets every day making
sure that my checklist was ticked off i
wouldn't leave that day if my checklist
wasn't ticked off the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincerie and the award-winning sauce
breaker